اذا بالفعل تزداد وتيره الاشتباكات بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
العاصمه الخرطوم وضواحيها مسرح المواجهات
الاقوى بنظره اقرب على العاصمه الخرطوم
هنا يمكننا الحديث عن اشتباكات في عده
مواقع هنا في محيط الخرطوم طبعا القصف
الجوي الذي نفذته قوات الجيش بالطائرات
هنا على مناطق سوبا شرق طبعا هذه الطائرات
من طراز ميغوسوي ابرز معالم المواجهات هو
هذا القصف ونفذته الطائرات في مناطق سوبا
شرق وفي الجريف شرق ايضا الخرطوم بحري
نتحدث هنا طبعا نحن شرق عندما نقول شرق هو
شرق نهر النيل تعلمون ان الخرطوم هي ملتقى
نيلين النيل الابيض والنيل الازرق ونشاهد
على هذه الخريطه ملتقى النيلين كما
تشاهدون القصف الجوي والاشتباكات تكرر هنا
في الخرطوم بحري ايضا
في الفتحاب هنا في جنوب ام درمان غربا
طبعا قوات الدعم السريع بدورها ردت على
هذه الغارات الجويه ردت عليها
بمضادات الطيران قبل ان تصدر بيانا تقول
فيه انها اسقطت احدى الطائرات من طراز
في وسط الخرطوم افاد مراسل الجزيره بسماع
دوي انفجارات هنا في محيط القصر الجمهوري
تصاحبها عاده نيران الاسلحه الثقيله
والخفيفه في هذه المناطق طبعا في سياق
المعارك يقول كلا الطرفين انه يتصدى
لمحاولات الطرف الاخر باستقدام تعزيزات من
بقيه المحافظات تقول القوات الجيش مثلا
انها تقصف ارتالا قادمه من لاسناد قوات
الدعم من هنا من شمال دارفور باتجاه
الصومال ايضا قوات الدعم السريع بانها
منعت تعزيزات الجيش من مناطق اخرى لتصل
الخرطوم بينما تحتدم الاشتباكات ها هنا في
وسط العاصمه الخرطوم كان لافتا ايضا اليوم
اعلان حاله الطوارئ
طبعا كان لافتا اعلان حاله الطوارئ في
البحر الاحمر لمده شهر في ولايه البحر
الاحمر شرقا بعد اعلانها بالامس طبعا ايضا
في ولايه كسلا هنا لمده شهر ايضا من المهم
ان نشير هنا الى ان ولايه البحر الاحمر
التي هي تشهد هذه العمليات اجلاء الاف
الرعايه الاجانب طبعا عبر المنفذ البحري
والجوي في مدينه بورتسودان